Snoopers gonna snoop
This is our home. Then let's fight for it
We are an unusual couple it was really so fun
getting to play all these different decades
throughout Wandavision we
just don't know what to expect
and then of course everything kind of breaks
down and becomes an mcu version of the real world
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are can't believe how it just
keeps unraveling and unfolding in ways
that i am still shocked and thrilled by
every day it's something different you know it's
high-tech marvel with helicopters flying around
and the next day it's a perfect recreation
of a 50s sitcom you know some days it's
it's both i think something's wrong here i think
it's going to be really satisfying for people
when they realize what is at the heart of this
show this is our home then let's fight for it
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision post credit scene video and episode
8 teaser trailer if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be
doing episodes for all the marvel disney plus
series this year falcon and winter soldier and
then loki or next there's going to be marvel
series pretty much every single month for the
rest of the year for the most part we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just post
all your theories about the Wandavision finale
on the video careful for spoilers for all the
Wandavision episodes so far if you haven't seen
any of them but we'll start with the post-credits
scene then i'll talk about evan peter's character
agatha harkness and the big reveal of the nexus
because that's probably one of the most important
concepts they introduced in addition to revealing
agatha harkins's identity during the episode
but in the post-credits scene monica rambeau makes
her way down the street to agatha harkness's house
address number 2804 remember vision in scarlet
witch live at number 2800 so ago the hartness
literally just lives right down the street from
them but i also believe the number 2804 is a
reference to a comic book easter egg and a clue to
her true plan what the nexus is all about on the
show why she's making wanda create the heck so
i'll talk about that in a second too because it
connects to a couple other things she walks around
the house and starts peeping into all the windows
and then makes her way to the basement seeing
all these vines growing out radiating with purple
energy implying that i get the harkness is in the
middle of weaving some giant spell because her
magic is purple like scarlet witch's energy is red
they're kind of color coding different characters
on the show monica rambeau's powers the energy
that she gives off is blue kind of like billy's
power they're doing that mostly so that you can
tell who is using their powers at any given moment
so that it all looks a little bit different and
more visually dynamic on screen but as she looks
into the basement she gets caught by evan peter's
character who says snooper's gonna snoop and then
you see her eyes glaze over with purple magic
implying that she's been mind controlled just
like scarlet witch and then they cut to black
so obviously the big question is what's going
to happen to monica rambeau next what exactly are
her powers how do they work and what is it exactly
that act of the harkness is doing with wanda
and what does that have to do with the nexus
so the most important thing i think in all this is
the idea of the nexus so that also gets into the
commercial from episode seven the nexus commercial
is a reference to a couple really big concepts
from the comics but it's a key metaphorically and
literally to everything that's happening on the
show so scarlet witch in the comics is what you
would call a nexus being someone that exists in
all realities she's like a constant across the
multiverse so you all know about the multiverse
you have different versions of characters in
different realities but in some realities some
characters don't exist like there's a reality
out there where there's no quicksilver but in
every single reality there is a scarlet witch this
will get you really excited for the loki series
and what's happening with ant-man 3 because one of
the other big nexus beings from the comics is kang
the conqueror all the king the conqueror's stuff
isn't necessarily relevant to what's happening
on Wandavision so i'll reference him at the end
of the video because we'll get into that when
we start talking about the loki episodes but the
nexus is also a place in the multiverse it's sort
of the nexus the focal point of all realities like
a gateway to all realities the brand new intro for
episode seven the parody of the office intro was
also sort of a riff on this idea of wanda being a
nexus being you see all the different versions
of wanda's name repeated in different kinds of
letters referencing that wanda exists in all these
different realities because wanda is a nexus being
she has this extra level of cosmic energy
all flowing through her she's sort of like a
focal point of the multiverse like a couple of
these other big characters like kang the conquer
it makes them way more powerful than normal
characters so on the show on Wandavision she
has all this extra cosmic energy flowing through
her they kind of teased that in earlier episodes
talking about how her reality warping magic works
but it's the reason why she has reality warping
powers because she is a nexus being there's also a
big catherine han spider-man into the spider-verse
multiverse storytelling connection so obviously
they're setting up a big multiverse plot because
of the doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
spider-man 3 spider-verse movie stuff in the mcu
but katherine han herself agatha harkness was
in spider-man into the spider-verse she played
doctor octopus during that who created a reactor
to give the kingpin access to the multiverse so a
new theory now why is agatha doing this why is she
taking advantage of scarlet witch why she trying
to manipulate her maybe she also has some trauma
in her history or she lost someone and that's why
she wants access to the nexus of all realities so
that she can search the multiverse for a version
of reality where whoever she lost is still alive
or whatever she might have lost is still alive if
you don't know much about agatha harkness in the
comics she actually debuted during the fantastic
four comics but she's ancient she was actually
burned at the stake during the salem witch trials
they haven't fully revealed how they're going to
change that for the tv show so i'm guessing that
mcu act of the harkness is a little bit different
from comic book agatha harkness because we don't
have the fantastic four yet there's been some
easter eggs so far but the connection with her
address 2804 marvel knights had a story from 2004
it was issue 27 so it's not quite exact but it was
a fantastic four story titled the resurrection of
nicholas scratch the sword agent that they sent
into the sewer the beekeeper his name was agent
franklin which i believe was a subtle reference
to franklin richards because obviously agatha the
hardness big character on the show agatha harkness
was franklin richard's nanny in the comics but
you have to consider why is agatha harkness doing
this why does she care so much about the nexus she
has to have a really strong emotional reason for
why she's manipulating wanda they have to have
something in common she has to be some sort of
dark twist on what's happening with wand on the
show in what is happening with her inside the
hex scarlet witch is trying to fabricate a family
for herself of all the people that she's lost she
lost vision so she wanted to bring him back inside
the hex and create this family with him but the
whole idea is that scarlet witch is dealing with
this trauma as vision just learned during episode
seven like he started to chill out a little bit oh
she's been through a lot she had to watch me die
multiple times think about what that did to
her emotionally so agatha harkness just has
to have something more in common with wanda
than just being another magical girl in town
and what would her reason be for wanting access to
the nexus it has to be something stronger and more
relatable than just trying to unleash a marvel
villain from the cosmos like the schumagorath or
nightmare or mephisto if that's the only reason
why she wants access to the nexus it would be
the most hammy reason ever it's more likely
that she also has some trauma in her history
that she's dealing with in a really terrible way
and she's just taking advantage of wanda to get
what she wants to try and fix or fill the hole
inside her in getting into the concept of the
hex the hex is probably key to making that happen
gaining access to the nexus creating a nexus which
might actually be happening inside this torture
basement that might be the focal point for where
this nexus is created it just seems like there's
so much magical energy radiating from this one
point inside the hex and you have her very dark
looking book of magic radiating with energy which
is probably the key to how she's manipulating
wanda so early theory agatha harkness and scarlet
witch have their full-blown wizard battle in the
finale and in messing with the multiverse in her
selfish pursuits they also inadvertently wind
up unleashing greater cosmic villains onto the
main mcu dimension like we're all wondering how
agatha the hardness is connected to the villain
of doctor strange too multiverse of madness maybe
she's serving nightmare mephisto schumachorth
like i said earlier or some other greater marvel
fearlord from another dimension like dormammu but
what if it's simpler than that she's just using
this magic book and wanda's powers to gain more
power so that she can get something that she wants
and in pursuit of that they wrecked the multiverse
wreck the nexus and that's the connection
to doctor strange 2 and benedict cumberbatch
even though it seems like there aren't any rules
in any of these comic book movies because they
break rules all the time in the comics there
are rules that explain why beings like dormammu
in the schumagorth nightmare even mephisto can't
just waltz into earth in the main marvel universe
and take over every single day because each of
them is that powerful they make it to planet
earth and they're each a thanos infinity gauntlet
level threat there are rules that they've created
in the comics for how the universe works and
explain why that doesn't happen every day that was
kind of what they got into during the first doctor
strange movie explaining what had to happen before
dormammu could absorb the main mcu dimension
into his own dark dimension or in guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 what had to happen before ego
the living planet could absorb the entire universe
dr strange is the person responsible for upholding
those cosmic rules but people break them all the
time sometimes on purpose sometimes on accident
as will probably be the case with Wandavision
so now a lot of you are asking what's going on
with evan peter's character on the show he looks
an awful lot like quicksilver from the fox x-men
films there are a lot of new theories now based on
this big twist him showing up and looking like
this at agatha harkness's house while monica
rambeau is sort of glazed over with that purple
energy did agatha harkness pull him from the fox
marvel universe did she manipulate the multiverse
to get him here to gaslight wanda a lot of people
are also now wondering if he's a version of
nicolas scratch agatha harkness's son from the
comics who's also a minor marvel villain himself
but on the show aka senior scratchy that she's
always carrying around that bunny he also might
be a version of her familiar because she's a witch
witches have familiars and he might just be able
to take human form and he looks like this even if
he is a version of nicolas scratch just to explain
how he might look like evan peters quicksilver
she knows all about the multiverse so she may just
be using evan peters quicksilver as inspiration
for the look of her version of quicksilver him
getting their backstory wrong would just fit
with him being a completely different person
who's just kind of winging it as they go along
but what's going to happen to monica rambeau now
that she's been captured and they're going to
throw her in that torture basement with scarlet
witch well they were very careful to show you
how monica rambeau was able to defend herself
and counter wanda's magical blast of red energy
earlier in the episode like agatha harkness's
purple magical energy will react the same way she
won't be able to completely control monica rambeau
and it'll be a learning experience for her as well
monica learning more about how her powers work so
when she was spectrum the way they explained her
powers she was able to transform herself into any
form of energy within the electromagnetic spectrum
she's also able to analyze and duplicate new
forms of energy as well so they're just hyping
up that she'll be able to soak a couple blasts
from act of the harkness and free herself from
this mind control but talking more about nexus
beings and the future of the mcu people like
hang the conqueror and the loki series with many
different loki's across the multiverse now it sort
of makes sense why they're giving us this story
now as sort of the introduction to nexus beings
the nexus of the multiverse because during the
loki series it's going to be loki working for the
time variance authority the loki from avengers
end game who escaped with the tesseract going
around acting like a time cop taking down other
versions of himself other loki's who are creating
havoc across different timelines they're sort
of giving you the rules in Wandavision for how
everything works so that they can play with those
rules in future marvel phase four projects but
everyone post all your theories in the comments
below what do you think agatha harkness is trying
to do with the nexus and with wanda as a nexus and
who do you think that evan peters character really
is is he a version of her familiar aka senior
scratchy like nicholas scratch or is he somebody
else my full episode 8 video will post next friday
but i'll do a couple other Wandavision bonus
videos before then there's a brand new falcon and
winter soldier trailer that'll be my next video
that should post sometime tomorrow so make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss that
i'll name a giveaway winner when I post that
falcon and winter soldier video but click here
for my full Wandavision episode 7 video and click
here for that other brand new falcon and winter
soldier trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!